the announcement came on monday from the
baltimore ravens facility closed
multiple positive covet 19 tests mark
ingram and jk dobbins among those that
tested positive that means they will not
be available for thursday night's game
against the pittsburgh steelers brandon
william will have to quarantine due to
close contact wow with them presuming
that happened on sunday because here's
what it means anytime you get a positive
test
on a monday that is announced in a team
statement that means on sunday before
the game they did the swab they sent it
off for pcr testing the most reliable
and accurate form of testing at a
laboratory away from the ravens facility
they show up for the game on sunday they
get the swab they find out sunday night
monday morning
that these guys were positive which
means chris yeah we're positive all day
sunday they were positive on the
sideline they were positive in the
locker room they were positive on the
field they were shedding virus i'm
surprised it's only brandon williams
because you know you think about it when
guys are on the sidelines and the nfl a
couple of weeks ago decided you know
what it's probably even more risky to
catch it on the sideline than on the
field because on the sideline they're
sitting out there still elbow to elbow
with masks not on they're not distancing
they're not wearing masks when they're
not in the game i'm surprised they
didn't knock out half the offense
frankly because what happens when the
offense isn't on the field they're all
huddled together trying to figure out
what they're going to do when they go
back on the field so
that's how it happens on a game day
and that means those guys were positive
on game day that means now the titans
players have to wonder whether at some
point this week they're going to end up
with a positive but for thursday night
two of the top running backs and i know
ingram has been phased out jk dobbins
has become the guy it's going to be
gus edwards leading the way for the
ravens running attack and remember last
time around now it was jackson edwards
and dobbins who generated 265 yards
against pittsburgh have a feeling
pittsburgh is going to be ready for that
this time definitely but it makes it a
lot tougher for the ravens to avoid
falling to six and five chris it
definitely does i mean man what a
development in a week like this after a
heartbreaking loss you're on the ropes
things like that yeah you got to deal
with this
you know and of course not being in the
facility all those issues wow it's going
to be an uphill battle for them this
week and you know to to what you're
talking about you're right like gus
edwards is still a really damn good
running back all of those type of things
definitely they'll miss jk dobbins
but
but like you know the the big thing is
like you said pittsburgh i i would just
totally expect them to be ready this
time they're not i would be shocked if
baltimore runs for 250 something yards
or flirts with that again
you know that was the first time
pittsburgh got to see lamar jackson in
that run offense too
you know so people we got to take that
into account that their defense first
time they really got so they're going to
be able to go okay now we know what to
expect a little here too but man the
ravens when it rains it pours and uh
right now they're really fighting
through some adversity here
and isn't this the ultimate opportunity
for lamar jackson to open it up down the
field throw the ball remember week one
last year when the dolphins basically
dared him to throw and he threw it all
day long we haven't seen that no what's
the issue there what did what did you
see from the film on sunday against the
titans to get any clues as to what's up
with the passing game well there there's
you know it's just we've talked about it
a few times throughout the year the fact
that there is no wide receiver
involvement in their offense is an issue
it does and it allows you to play
certain parts of the field with the
baltimore ravens you know i watched the
film yeah you know i'm ron jaworski
that's one of the things i wanted to
watch yesterday what the hell did
tennessee do to baltimore you know the
first thing you start to realize is you
watch baltimore you know yes okay people
have caught on to the run game and do
that but the big thing is
the run game would be fine if there was
more to be scared about in the past game
because all that becomes becomes is stop
the up the middle run stop lamar on the
edge stop mark andrews who's going to be
up the middle too right there in your
area so it's all right there in between
the hashes all the time you know and i
sit there every week and i write all
these notes and the other thing i always
write is lack of wide receiver
involvement do they ever throw the ball
outside the numbers or that part of the
field and i said it during the podcast
yesterday and i go hey pete demillo
lightest look up the numbers baltimore's
the worst in football throwing the ball
outside the numbers so you know there
they go
they're the run game right at you right
off the edge mark andrews down the
middle and then there's this big faction
in the field that you don't really have
to defend when you play baltimore
because they don't get the wide
receivers involved and they don't throw
to certain areas of the field and to me
that is playing hand to hand a little
bit with the the issues of their offense
their run game and things like that
you know it could be the scheme it could
be lamar but let me throw one other
possibility at you the struggles in
attracting veteran free agent receivers
that's well established now sure guys
who have options are not going to choose
to join on with a run-based offense and
when you rely on the draft to get your
receivers how do you ever develop your
receivers if you're not using them in
the passing game sure it's the chicken
and the egg thing right we talk all the
time about how the great receivers are
coming into the nfl because it's seven
on seven from the time they're seven
years old
they get to the nfl the development
stops because they don't throw the ball
enough to let these guys reach their
ceiling yeah no mike i think there's
there's certainly something to that you
know there's just not enough diversity
in the pass game in the offense you know
little cheap ways to creatively get wide
receivers to football do anything like
that
there's nothing there to be had and
listen i'm not trying to sit here and
tell you lamar jackson is patrick
mahomes or aaron rodgers or russell
wilson but ralmar jackson is still damn
good and lamar jackson you know the one
thing i i don't like about the last few
weeks is it's all on him lamar lamar
lamar lamar and i just go i watched the
villain i watched the film about the
film he's not egregiously like missing
people wide open all over the field it's
not like i'm coming away from these
games going man he left like 200 yards
on the field there was people open he's
missing throws no it's not perfect i
understand he threw the interception but
for the most part if people get open
lamar jackson's going to hit you he's
good enough to do that and dice you up
that way and they need to help him
nobody's perfect okay
is it the receivers or is it i think
it's your greg roman i think it's more
greg roman and the offensive coaching
staff right now that to me is more of
the i
hey you know like hollywood brown has he
been a little bit of a disappointment as
a first run pick definitely but they can
still find ways to cheaply get him the
ball and do little things here and there
we just they don't even get the ball in
his hands and to me there's no excuse
for that and and that's their biggest
problem i think it's just predictability
of where the ball's gonna go and who's
gonna have it in their hands is really
hurting them right now because their run
game has been caught onto a little bit
you know i think the organization wanted
nothing to do with antonio brown
hollywood's cousin but maybe maybe they
could have used antonio brown because
antonio brown maybe would be the guy
getting open outside the numbers that
lamar jackson could throw to and in it
funny what a difference a year makes and
it just shows you how flawed the nfl's
broader process of identifying hot
coaching candidates is the winning teams
the best teams well there oh wink
martindale and greg roman now this year
not a peep because the team's struggling
same coaches same guys yeah same ideas
right same concepts different year it's
somebody else from the successful teams
that becomes the hot coaching candidate
robert sala we're not hearing his name
this year because the 49ers aren't what
they were last year same coach same guy
same ideas same concepts it just shows
you how inherently flawed it is when
you've got the owners who aren't
football people getting caught up in the
same things we get caught up in right
the assistant coach is on the best team
so uh look they've got to do something
in baltimore because the season really
is on the brink mike tomlin has
recognized the steelers head coach that
that they have to match that level of
desperation that baltimore is going to
be bringing to town because this is it
for the ravens if they lose no chance of
winning the division and the chances of
getting to the playoffs are going to
plummet now the schedule gets easier on
the back end but still
they they are falling apart and i think
they're realizing that 2020 is a far cry
from what 2019 was for the ravens yeah
definitely and you know
to the the point of like you know you
talk about with pittsburgh trying to
match their desperation too hey for them
you know the big prize in the sky should
be you got a chance to to deal the death
blow to a team that you know
is would be scary to play in the
playoffs the ravens get him now get him
get him get him out you don't got to
deal with them right because i won't
want you don't want to see them come to
town divisional weekend or anything like
that after they've won a what you know
wild card game and maybe got some
momentum who knows so yeah this is their
chance to cancel them out
does a win thursday night by the ravens
erase the ugliness we've seen the past
few weeks from them i don't know if it
erases it you know i don't know and i
guess it's going to be a little bit how
they win that football game but i think
the big thing you know i just want to
see is just a little more diversity you
know i do you know i want to see they
got to spread the field out a little bit
more you know that's the other thing
that i come to so much too so many
condensed sets so many things right here
in front of you to where defenses don't
have to spread out that's a little bit
of the beauty of like kylo murray in
arizona they spread you out so therefore
when he does get on the loose there's a
lot of space baltimore is a little bit
the opposite they keep everybody in
smash mouth up the middle okay i get
that you have to worry about that you
pack them in there and then they get
lamar jackson on the edge on the outside
of you but teams have understood and
figured out how to defend the edge while
also kind of defending that inside power
run game on them and now there needs to
be a next chess move in my opinion and
they've yet to hit that next chess move
to improve their offense and help their
team out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports